SPEAKER 1: Kubernetes--
I hear everyone
has been talking about
it, and you've probably
heard of it, too.
It's become pretty popular,
and I think it's time
to learn what it is.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With a whole universe
of things to learn,
it's important to start
with the essentials.
Let's go over the
concepts that make
Kubernetes usable, scalable,
and just downright awesome.
Are you ready?
Hey, [INAUDIBLE].
Good to see you.
I was just going over
what Kubernetes is.
SPEAKER 2: That sounds like fun!
Kubernetes is a portable,
extensible, open-source
platform for managing
containerized workloads
and services that facilitates
both declarative configuration
and automation, letting
you run distributed
systems resiliently,
with scaling and failover
for your application.
SPEAKER 1: OK,
well, that's a lot.
Do you have a way
to simplify that?
SPEAKER 2: Good call.
Basically, it's a
container orchestrator
that helps make sure that
each container is where
it's supposed to be and that the
containers can work together.
SPEAKER 1: Oh,
that makes me think
of a conductor that manages
everything in an orchestra.
Are the horns going?
Oh, the drums-- they
should be going now.
SPEAKER 2: Exactly.
There's a lot of moving points
in a scalable application.
Just like a conductor
makes sure the song sounds
like a composer
wants, Kubernetes
makes sure services
are running smoothly
the way an app developer wants.
SPEAKER 1: Mmm.
OK, before we get into more
details about the what,
let's go over why
it was created.
See, there are a
lot of applications
that we call
monoliths, which means
they put all the
functionality, like transaction
and third-party integration,
into a single deployable
artifact.
SPEAKER 2: And monoliths
are a common way
to build applications,
even today.
But they still have
their downfalls.
For example, deployments
can take a long time,
since everything has to
roll out all together.
And if different
parts of the monolith
are managed by
different teams, there
could be a lot of
additional complexity
when prepping for a rollout.
SPEAKER 1: And scaling
has the same problem.
Teams have to throw resources
at the whole application,
even if the bottleneck
is only on a single area.
SPEAKER 2: Right.
So people came up
with microservices.
Each piece of functionality
is split apart
into smaller
individual artifacts.
If there's an update,
only that exact service
has to be replaced.
SPEAKER 1: And the
microservice model
has scaling benefits, too.
Now individual services can be
scaled to match their traffic,
so it's easier to
avoid bottlenecks
without over-provisioning.
SPEAKER 2: This is
all great, but having
one machine for
each service would
require a lot of resources
and a whole bunch of machines.
SPEAKER 1: That's why containers
are the perfect choice.
With containers, teams can
package up their services
neatly.
All the applications,
their dependencies,
and any necessary configuration
get delivered together.
This also means that they can
be sure their services will
run the same way, no
matter where they're run.
SPEAKER 2: But there
are still more problems
that remain unsolved.
Upgrading a container
is easy, since you
can create a new
version of the container
and deploy it in
place of the old one.
But how can upgrades be
done without downtime?
How do these containers know
how to talk to the other ones?
And how can the app
developer debug issues
and observe what's happening?
SPEAKER 1: And now
we've come back
to the conductor of our
container orchestra.
Kubernetes is all about
managing these containers
on virtual machines or nodes.
The nodes in the
containers they run
are grouped together
as a cluster,
and each container has
endpoints, DNS, storage,
and scalability.
SPEAKER 2: Everything
that modern applications
need, without the manual
effort of doing it yourself.
Kubernetes automates most of the
repetition and inefficiencies
of doing everything by hand.
The app developer
tells Kubernetes
what it wants the
cluster to look like,
and Kubernetes makes it happen.
SPEAKER 1: See, this
all sounds amazing.
So everyone should just
switch to Kubernetes, yeah?
SPEAKER 2: Well, not so fast.
Microservices still have
their own unique challenges,
and sometimes a monolith
can be the right solution,
based on what's right for
the application itself.
And monoliths can still
run on Kubernetes,
even though they won't be able
to use all the same benefits.
SPEAKER 1: Either
way, how do you
know when you're ready to
get started with Kubernetes?
SPEAKER 2: Well, the first step
is to start using containers.
That's easier said
than done, but let's
save that for the next episode.
SPEAKER 1: OK, so
now we have an idea
of what kinds of problems
Kubernetes helps with,
and we've also got an orbital
view of what it actually does.
SPEAKER 2: Yep.
Next time, let's
dig into containers.
SPEAKER 1: Containers, huh?
OK, stay tuned, everybody.
If you want to get
hands on, check out
the link in the description.
And if you enjoyed the
episode, subscribe for more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]